hello everyone and welcome to game four
of the World Chess Championship match
between Yani punishi and Dean libren in
the first three games you've seen what
happened in game one nipple had a pretty
good game but in the end it ended in a
draw game two ended by ding losing and
nepo took an early lead in the match and
in game three uh it's like ding came
back a new person uh he played a very
nice game he had some chances not
winning chances but there were chances
that could potentially lead to positions
that could be considered you know
something that you would play for a win
in the end they uh repeated moose and
the position ended in a draw but now we
are in game four uh the game is really
beautiful you guys will enjoy it so
let's check it out but before that we
have a nice photo of the handshake
before the game there you have it um
nipple shaking your ding's hand he's
like put their little dude uh I'm
leading the match and I'm looking very
much forward to My World Chess
Championship belt and here we have a
very nice photo of the first move being
made by Mike Klein also known as chess
Mike you can see that the players are
having a very good laugh as Micah played
Pawn to B3 but the ding did not go for
Pawn to B3 so that being said let's
check it out the ding has the white
pieces and now he opens with Pawn to see
for so not Pawn to e for not Pawn to D4
but Pawn to C4 uh let's see what the
ding and Rapport came up with four game
four with the white piece it's Knight to
F6 with Knight to C3 E5 by nipple Knight
to F3 and Knight to C6 the Four Knights
of the English are on the board we have
E3 and Bishop to B4 so nothing new here
uh Queen to C2 and now Bishop captures
in C3 and now the standard way of
replying is Queen captures and C3 in
order not to mess up your Pawn structure
but here we have B captures and C3 uh
Pawn to D6 and now Ponte for preparing
to grab the full center with Ponte D4
and the queen from C2 nicely guarding
that e for Pawn we have Castles by
nipple Bishop to E2 and now Knight the
H5 preparing to put the Knight on F4 we
have Pawn to D4 by D and now the
immediate Knight to F4 by nip also very
interesting is just Queen to F6 it looks
weird because you kind of run into
Bishop to G5 but it doesn't do all that
much for white you can just play Queen
to G6 and uh it's it's a good position
for black so basically after Queen to F6
you have to play something like G3 in
order to prevent Knight to F4 but then
you go back and then maybe F5 later on
uh it's a very very interesting position
uh but nipple went for Knight to F4
right away and the ding just captured
Bishop captures an F4 we have e captures
on F4 and the interesting thing is that
this is a position that Ding secondary
have Rapport already had 10 years ago in
2013 he had it against uh zargotsky and
Bundesliga and he won a very nice game
but in that game the game continued to
pawn to H4 and you could
um do a lot of damage with the spawn to
hormu let's say black continues
developing you play Pawn to H5 Bishop to
G4 uh even Pawn to H6 and this is
something that definitely resembles a
style that you would expect from a
regard Rapport let's say g690 D2 and
even in Bishop captures you're gonna
boldly go into the center with your king
let's say queen t7 and you would get
some uh weird position like this but
okay uh if you if you enjoyed you can
play it uh after he captures an F4 ding
just Castle King side so a rapportending
prepared something else
um uh deviating from that game uh Queen
to F6 by nipple and now Rook F the E1 we
have rooked the E8 and now Bishop to D3
and everyone was very skeptical of this
bishop the D3 move by ding as it sort of
really invites Bishop to G3 and solves
all of nepo's developing problems
um more likely something that Rook 8 to
B1 can be can be played which hinders
the development of the light Square
version but still after rokita B1 and B6
you're still gonna play roket to D1 so
maybe it's just better to play Roketa D1
right away and now you might consider
something like Queen to G6 going after
the E4 pawn and now the reason why it
wasn't played is probably because you
have to play a silly move like Queen to
C1 and if you don't have this prepared
the chances are you're not gonna find
this at the board now the E4 Pawn is
defended with a tactic of course the
queen characters is impossible because
Bishop D3 just traps the black queen and
Rook captures on e4 is impossible
because of Queen to B1 and look at this
now pretty silly stuff and now uh once
you play a move let's say something like
Bishop to G4 uh you're gonna see Knight
the H4 attacking the queen guarding the
F5 square and you don't have a way to
defend the The Rook here because if you
move just Pawn to D5 and you just get
destroyed so you can't play Bishop G4
you're gonna have to play something like
Pawn to F5 but already it's a very very
weird position to play like Bishop to D3
you're gonna trade here captures
captures and this just looks weird uh so
you know many many tricks and uh funny
moves in the position but okay ding goes
for Bishop to D3 obviously it goes uh
within the theme of something he and
rapper discussed uh Bishop to G4 and
apple play this fairly instantly and now
Knight the D2 of course you're not gonna
allow captures and now comes Knight the
A5 by nipple nipple really likes to put
his Knights on the on the rim uh the the
other moves that could be considered
here are Ponte F3 like it really looks
like a good move
uh because it kind of ruins white spawn
structure the problem is that both the
G3 and H3 are perfectly fine for white
like if H3 uh black will play Bishop
captures on H3 in hopes of checkmating
the white king but you're just gonna
play Knight captures and F3 and after
the bishop goes back you're just gonna
play Rook to E3 defend the Knight you're
gonna double up on the file and you're
gonna have a a great game on the other
hand you might also consider Rook 8 to
d8 now it's a it's a move like any other
you just bring the Rook into the game
let's say Pawn to H3 Bishop back to D7
and now rotate the D1 and the game
continues something like B6 let's say
Knight to F3 and now nipple could even
consider ideas like Pawn to G5 Pont H5
Pawn to G4 if he wishes to play a game
like that but as the game progresses uh
you will see that this is not the kind
of game that he wants to play with
Knight to A5 and now uh Pawn to C5 by
ding the immediate Pawn to C4 now uh
just uh give you an idea of what also
could have been played uh Queen to A4 is
a really nasty idea by white because it
puts pressure on the Knight and also
takes away the D7 Square from the black
bishop and now if B6 defending the
Knight now F3 is a little bit different
now you don't have Bishop to D7 the
queen covers that square so the bishop
has to go back now Knight the B3 attacks
the Knight and you don't really have
uh good squares squares for the 90
because something like Knight the B7
then E5 attacks the queen followed by
Bishop to E4 uh you run into some
serious trouble here you're gonna have
to trade here and you get the nice
semi-open file for your for your Roka
and the AFL you can double up on the a
file uh it looks to be very promising
for white but okay again ding has a
different plan he plays Pawn to C5 and
now D captures on C5 by nepo uh it's uh
you know that the ding will not capture
back with the D capitals and C5 so
obviously C5 is a pawn Sacrifice by Ding
and nepo accepts it D captures on C5 and
it's objectively the best move uh Ponte
E5 attacks the queen queen to H6 and now
Pawn to D5 we didn't gets the massive
Center here Rook 8 to d8 and now Pawn to
C4 just defending his center with B6 by
nipple and now Pawn to H3 chasing away
the bishop you knew that this move was
coming sooner or later Bishop to H3 and
now how can ding continued this position
it's uh not easy to figure out a a way
to do this it's a very very uh well it
is just very hard to find a way to
improve you already have the strong
Center your queen and Bishop are already
controlling this beautiful diagonal okay
you can put the Knight on F3 or to E4
and you have to decide where the Rook on
A1 is going probably the D1 or you would
be also very happy if you could double
up on the E file but how to connect all
of those ideas here ding finds Bishop to
E4 and it's a very nice move uh also
this is defended by a tactic if you
capture just Bishop captures and H7
check wins that Rook so Rook the E7 by
nepo and now Queen to C3 Queen to C3 uh
you'll see a very fine move with Rook
dito E8 nipple doubles up on the D file
the situation on the clock if you guys
are interested is 55 minutes for for
Ding and for 41 minutes for nipple uh
and here we have Bishop to F3 and this
is a really awesome because ding really
has to choose between Bishop to F3 and
something like Bishop to C2 to A4
because the bishop needs to go to this
diagonal now if you go Bishop to C2
right away let's say queen to G5 you're
going to play Bishop to A4 you're gonna
attack the root let's say Pawn to C6 uh
you get a very very complicated position
D captures and C6 now Queen to G6 ready
to capture back but now C7 attacks The
Rook uh by the bishop on A4 Rook def 8
and now even Pawn to E6 in order to save
the C7 Pawn F captures an E6 and now
Queen to E5 defending the pawn here for
example Pawn to H6 preparing Queen to G5
and now Rook 8 to C1 we have Queen to G5
Queen to D6 defending and now even Pawn
to F3 and this is a position I think no
one can calculate and probably why ding
gave up on the whole idea because I mean
look at this it's just one big mess so
instead after this Rook DTE ding went
for Bishop to F3 he still has the option
of going Bishop to D1 to A4 but he's
asking nepo if he's maybe interested in
trading and then ding gets the get his
Knight to uh to a better Square uh but
nipple just plays Knight back to B7 he
doesn't even bother capturing or playing
Bishop to G6 uh and now we have Rook the
E2 ding now ready to double up on the E
file and although the Knight is kinda
back in the game it's hard to say where
the Knight is really going uh uh he will
uh probably uh F6 is coming at some
point to then and ding will have to push
E6 if he doesn't want to mess up his
Pawn structure in the center and then
nipple will get the D6 Square for his
Knight is the most likely idea and
that's exactly what happens here you
could also consider capturing but first
we have F6 and now how do you continue
here uh basically ding has the decide
whether he wants to push E6 or he wants
the plane uh something else like Rook 81
you could also consider doubling up on
the e-file but other than E6 there's
really nothing if you consider doubling
up here let's say F characters and E5
Rook captures and E5 after Queen F6 you
can just resign with white how do you
how do you deal with this uh you can't
even give up the two Rooks for the queen
because the rookon 88 is defended is
just Queen captures and now this is
pointless so E6 is basically the only
move for ding Ponte E6 and now comes
Knight to D6 by nipple
uh also you could consider Bishop
captures on F3 uh it's uh it's a very
tricky move but if you didn't play it on
the previous move now it really doesn't
make sense for you to play it because if
you played on the previous move when the
pawn was still on E5 Queen characters on
E5 would have been impossible as the
queen also was uh guarding the pawn here
but now uh both Queen characters and
Knight captures is possible so if you
really wanted to capture probably on the
previous movie it would have been better
so Knights the D6 by nippo and now Rook
8 to E1 by ding ding just doubles up on
the E file we have Knight to the F5 a
beautiful Square for nepo's Knight and
now uh Bishop captures on H5 now abiding
Bishop captures and G4 also an
incredibly tricky move uh the problem is
uh how do you deal with this if you go
Knight to the D4 then Rook the E4 and if
Bishop to G6 then just Rook captures on
D4 you're gonna give up The Rook for the
exchange here captures captures and the
white has a spectacular Pawn structure
here the very strong Bishop denied it
that's able to go uh you know something
like B1 c3b5 then put pressure on
Black's entire position so it would be
very very hard to play against this
setup but ding actually plays Bishop
captors on H5 Queen captures on H5 and
now Rook the E4 ding now forces nepo to
deal with the uh with the double pawn
and F4 and nepo just defended Queen to
H6 and now we have Queen to F3 and here
something unimaginable happen now the F4
Pawn is attacked twice and everyone
thought alright since Nepal pretty much
played this entire game setting up
everything to be able to push this Pawn
to G5 Pawn to G5 is probably coming now
and after that something like let's say
G4 and only then after G4 is played the
Knight will go to D6 Kick Back The Rook
rule goes back they do something like
Queen to G6 and nippo has a very nice
play here he has H5 whenever he wants he
has F5 whenever he wants the Knight is
controlling C4 so you can't really move
the knight from D2 uh I mean it's a it's
a fine position okay black uh rocks
aren't really doing all that much but
you can't really do much with those
spawns uh you know either way but
instead after Queen to F3 nipple did not
play Pawn to G5 it seems like G5 was
never on his mind because he just played
Knight to D4 and that can only mean one
thing he never even considered uh the
move that Ding played on the next move
so feel free to pause the video for
those of you who haven't seen the game
live and find the absolute best move for
ding while I give you a couple of
seconds
foreign so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on
spotting this uh incredible positional
uh idea and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is Rook
captures on D4 uh that's the move
they're being played and now nipple is
in big trouble now of course you're
you're probably wondering what happens
if Queen captures that's probably what
nipples uh uh saw when he played Knight
to D4 he saw that this is not a problem
in any way because he's just gonna trade
and play C6 and that's it pretty much
ruin ruined his Pawn structure let's say
Knight F3 Knight captures real capture C
captures and d5c captures Rook to d8 and
stop those pawns because if you remember
black was up upon any frog the one
you're just gonna block those pawns uh
Rook to D6 or even better if Rook the D3
then Rook to D6 and the pawns have been
blockaded now it's uh I mean it's a dead
draw if anything it will be black we'll
be able to undermine them and maybe get
some sort of an edge so that was Nepal's
idea but after Knight the D4 Dean played
the move you all found Rook captures on
D4 and I'll look it is C counters on D4
and now Knight to B3 this is the star
move not The Rook captures on d41 Knight
the B3 is the star move because now you
see Knight captures on D4 is coming and
then the Knight has access to c6n to the
F5 squares and now there is no way to
play this D3 seems like the the move you
want to play because it's a sort of um
defense against that capture Sun D4 and
forces the White Queen to move from such
an active Square then maybe you find
some counter play with Pawn to F3 but I
don't think nepo is in the mindset to
look for such ideas after he blundered
to this he just played Pawn to G5 now
and now Knight captures on D4 we have
Queen to G6 and now ding just plays Pawn
to G4 and uh uh when ding was
sacrificing The Rook sacrificing The
Exchange and leave for his hands his
hand was shaking and he almost dropped
the Rook when he was about to sacrifice
it but when he pushed G4 here he was it
was like he was uh you know it was like
he was creating a an earthquake he just
played it so firmly he knew that he was
completely winning here so he played G4
uh now the Knight is coming to a fight
once the night lands it's game over the
Rooks and the Queen have no moves for
the rest of the game so nepo is forced
to play F captures on G3 Alpha saw F
captures we have Pawn the H5 now but it
doesn't matter just Knight to F5 attacks
The Rook here Rook the H7 and now Queen
to E4 with some nasty threats of Knight
A7 check winning the black queen here so
King the h8 sidestepping check and now
Pawn to E7
and uh nipple uh kind of gave Ding A
look here when the spawn 37 was played
because ding played it instantly an
episode okay aren't you gonna maybe
think a little bit more about the
position but it is the strongest move
recommended by the engine and it really
uh limits the mobility of Black's pieces
even more blacks only Contra play with
the queen with something like Queen to
GH f8 but now even that is impossible
due to the E7 Pawn here so here or you
could play G4 but then H4 this doesn't
really change anything so king a queen
to F7 was played in order to stop Queen
to E6 but now Dean just plays Pawn to D6
it is absolutely sufficient C captures
Knight captures now Forks the queen and
the Rook we have Queen to G8 Knight
captures Queen captures and now just
Queen to E6 so going after the F6 Pawn
so King the G7 defending it and now Rook
the F1 and this is a fine way to
uh to uh bring the game to its end uh
forcing Rook to H6 and only now Rook to
D1 preparing Rook 38 uh with F5 now
attacking ding's Queen here but Queen to
F5 with the check King to F7 now nipples
only plan is for ding to uh not blunder
one move probably not even blunder two
moves ding would have to blunder three
moves in a row in order to lose this it
would be
I would be uh unimaginable for this to
happen but okay Queen captures an F5
with check we have Rook to F6 and now
Queen to H7 with check King to E6 and
down Queen to G7 and that's uh pretty
much all there is there's no move for
black here the never played Rook to G6
but now Queen to f8 uh and he was in
this position and move 47 that Yani
polish you resigned in the game and
dingliren is back in the match so both
players um win their games uh before a
rest today and now a ding is going very
happy into the rest day and nepo is
going I imagine very sad into a rest day
uh I um I still haven't uh watched the
press conference I will after I make
make the video but I'm sure he was very
very sad about everything that happened
here uh either way uh a game two and
four uh the ones where we've had this uh
really awesome Surprise by adding
secondary Rapport in you know in in the
opening part of the of the game uh was a
very impressive of end I hope we
continue seeing this and it will be very
interesting to see how Nepal deals with
it the Ponte H3 surprise didn't go so
well for ding but this one went very
very well but it you know even if
everything was looking perfectly fine
but nepo just completely blundered the
game away so here problem is after Rook
to G8 you're just gonna play Rook to d8
and that's it
and you're gonna be up too much material
let's say Rook capture seat captures uh
brings the queen into the game
characters captures uh you're gonna be
up a full Rook so that's why of course
here you resign but yeah it all came
down to this point and it wasn't the
perfect game by either of them you know
uh maybe maybe more optimal moves could
have been made but it's very hard to say
I mean you ask this engine this move is
more optimal as this engine this move is
more optimal so they've they both played
pretty much uh a great game up until
this point but here nipples Knight to D4
just uh it's like he it's like he didn't
even uh consider Rook capture Sandy for
a possibility because it if you put
yourself now in this position and you uh
and you consider this captures and
captures even if you don't find Knight
to B3 right away how are you ever
getting those Rooks into the game I mean
it's uh even if you just give this
knight uh uh 50 moves there there's
pretty much nothing black can do here
the Knight will find its way to F5 to C6
I mean the black Position will just
shatter so uh very weird for nepo uh
it's uh uh sort of like like maybe
against Magnus after game six where he
just started playing poorly but here
there was no breaking point for him or
anything he just uh made a terrible
blunder for no particular reason and it
will be very interesting to see if this
is something that will be reoccurring
throughout the the rest of the World
Chess Championship match but okay it's
still early only game four has finished
uh we'll see what happens in the uh you
know uh game five and so on and so on uh
so yeah that's the game I hope you guys
enjoyed it I would like to thank
yaroslav simbita and Matthew Benoit the
JB Christian Janet and the James Cashman
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the World Chess Championship
until it finishes so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day